Tom hello Lucifer is in crisis on
Infinite Earths you told me he was not
why did you why this is what happens I
go to Vancouver for the weekend to visit
my friend for his birthday and now
suddenly I'm in a different show
well there's photos of you it looks like
you're in costume no well that's very
strong why didn't you mislead all right
well because right so yes he is he is in
the crossover and what when I went to go
and shoot this team we we were talking
on set beforehand myself and Matt Ryan
and we were like this is so exciting
wouldn't it be amazing if we could keep
this a secret for the fans until they
actually see it on the screen that night
and of course these days that's not that
possible with social media I tell and I
think there was a few people hanging
around the set who noticed that I was
there and so put stuff out that I was
going to be in it so I kind of was like
well I would still would really like
this or you know surprise some people
sure so that is why okay well yeah there
was that I was actually genuinely there
for my friend's birthday they're not a
true liar no no I was just economical
with the truth okay I mean he did say
hard pass so that's a no that's not
happening
sorry only cuz I'm not saying that
passed how long have you had to keep
this a secret for gosh I think about
three and a half months I think it was
just before we started shooting season
final and Lucifer they came to me asked
me about it was it an immediate yes when
they asked you to be part of it it was
actually really yeah it was but well
there was a there was numerous reasons
one we started shooting we didn't season
one and two of Lucifer in Vancouver so I
was a big place in my heart for
Vancouver so it was an opportunity to go
back and see some friends and do all
that sort of stuff but also on the on
the work side of it it was just you know
we talked over the years about this
Lucifer being a DC character and is
there any chance of this happening and I
honestly thought there wasn't so when
they said I was like yeah let's do
yeah and I know Matt a little bit as
well and we talked about it in the past
so made it happen
we made it yeah dude we manifested it
you did how do you think fans now that
they've seen the episode are reacting to
this news well I hope reacting with
pleasure I don't know really I mean like
I say that's why I wanted to keep it
surprise because I'm really with all
these characters that we do know they
were happening in the crossover we just
wanted it to be you know something that
would surprise and it'd be a nice little
Easter egg I think they call these days
anything that's what the kids call
Easter Egg Easter Egg yes let's talk
about Lucifer in this amazing crossover
episode when you first read the script
and the part that he was going to have
in the episode what were your thoughts
uh well it was a it was really fun
actually because we so we're playing it
as if it's in the five years before the
show Lucifer started so when Lucifer
spent five years in LA before meeting
the detective and all those things
unfolding so this is him in his proper
like playboy don't give a damn about
anything kind of stage in his life yeah
and so he's um he's very irreverent with
our characters when they turn up in the
scene and obviously with Constantine
there's some history there sure I met
and I had a lot of fun playing about
with that how familiar were you with
Lucifer and Constantine's friendship
relationship I mean relatively familiar
but there's a kind of like lizard for
grudging sort of admiration amongst the
two of them yeah I think this is the
first time that were actually seeing
Constantine and Lucifer on-screen
together boys why was now the right time
in this story to sort of make that
happen with these crossover episodes it
opens up a world in which they can make
a money experiment with time and all
that sort of stuff so it felt like if
there was ever gonna be an opportunity
this was it sure you know what was it
like working with I mean you know Matt
but I show up with David with hat on set
that it was really fun I turned up on
set and I said hello David remember mean
it was like yeah man we fell off the
stage together at comic-con
we did you really we did we did the
penalty we did a panel a few years ago
comic-con and at the end of the
like a photo right and there's a
backdrop and we didn't realize the
backdrop wasn't solid it was just like a
floating curtain so we will start moving
back and leaning against it and then all
of a sudden would you slow so yeah that
was our bonding moment a few years ago
so we had a laugh about that no injuries
are falling down no no no there was no
injuries in the making of this one no
okay
was there a favorite part to filming
this scene well I mean I think going but
being able to revisit the the Lucifer
before where Lucifer is now in our story
was a lot of fun with it a little bit
challenging for you because of where
Lucifer is at these days sort to sort of
revert back weirdly no weirdly no cuz I
you know obviously you know he's stuck
with me this whole progression of the
character but just to to go back to the
world really doesn't really care about
anybody other than himself is weirdly
quite easy for me to get through but I
feel like you're so good at playing all
versions of Lucifer that's what makes it
oh thank you so good I think thank you
that your job does this open up doors to
maybe see Lucifer and other realms of
the arrow verse moving well that is it
that's a question for the DC bosses not
for me would you want to it alright why
I never say never
okay I never say never do you have an
idea in your head of what that could
look like
I'd like this would have been a
superhero costume at some point though
that that fun
lose the touch and all of a sudden he's
in spending time to tone although he is
kind of like the ultimate most powerful
yeah he is the most powerful dad yeah
from dad last time I did talk to you you
mentioned maybe possibly guest stars in
the final season of Lucifer could it be
anybody from the air oh well no you
don't believe my arms is anymore so it's
hard to say well I mean if there's
episodes coming up to this point no but
if there were episodes where someone
company but I doubt it to be honest okay
I doubt it cuz it doesn't quite tie in
with our story of where we're at the
moment sure especially now because that
was a different time
in two years all this time travel is
very confusion it is it's hard to keep
up I thought when the clocks go forward
do you have a message to the fans now
that they've seen this surprise episode
well yeah I do thank you for watching
and if you haven't seen Lucifer but
you're an arrow fan and now you've seen
lutheran arrow why don't you watch this
[Music]